Katie Holmes gushes over her daughter  Suri Cruise she makes every day great  [Music]  the 37-year old actress tells the New  York Times her daughter with ex-husband  Tom Cruise is the quote inspiration  behind everything she adds Suri is a  remarkable person and that she really  enjoys having a ten-year-old we're just  gonna figure it out as we go this isn't  the first time katie has sang her praise  Katie who is making her directorial  debut with her latest drama all we had  out December 9th opened up to eat see in  October about how she gave her daughter  a shout out in her film I gave my  daughter a special thanks at the end she  gets a special thanks for everything  every job I do because she makes every  day great and awesome and better and I  know myself more because of her so  she'll always get a special thanks  you